يوم ليس كباقي الايام على العراق التاسع
من نيسان قبل 20 عام هناك لطلائع الدبابات
الامريكيه في قلب بغداد تعبر على جسر
الجمهوريه في لقطه رسمت مشهدا ضبابيا على
مختلف الصعد
لتصل بعدها فرقه من مشاه البحريه
الامريكيه الى ساحه الفردوس وتسقط تمثال
الرئيس الاسبق صدام حسين معلنه اسقاط نظام
وبدء عهد جديد
قائم على اسس الديمقراطيه كما تزعم
الولايات المتحده
اذا سقط نظام صدام حسين
لتبدا اعمال السلب والنهب وسرقه المؤسسات
الحكوميه بشكل شبه منظم من اقصى جنوب
العراق وصولا الى شماله
حلم اسقاط النظام تحول بنظر كثيرين الى
كابوس بات يؤرق العراقيين في صحوهم
ومنامهم اكثر المتفائلين واشد المتشائمين
لم يرسموا في مخيلتهم مشهدا كالذي عاشه
العراق طيله العشرين سنه الماضيه الان
سيبدا او بدات بوادر النضوج الفكري
والسياسي حول المشاريع الوطنيه رغم انها
متجذره كواقع حقيقه الامر ولكن كمشروع
امثل هو المنقذ العراق هو المشروع الواقعي
والمشروع الوطني لينقذ العراق من شمال
العراق الى جنوب العراق كان مسؤول على 3
قضايا مهمه اللي هي اسلحه الدمار الشامل
وعلاقته بسبتمبر ويؤدد الامن والسلم
الدوليه وثبت انه هذه الثلاثه هي حقيقه ما
موجوده حقيقه الامر
حجه التدخل العسكري كانت اسلحه الدمار
الشامل والتي لم يجد لها الاميركان ومن
معهم اثرا حتى بعد عشرين عاما من الخراب
والدمار في بلاد ما بين النهرين
لتخلف من بعدها نظاما لا يزال اباؤه
المؤسسون يقولون انه في بداياته ولم ينضج
بعد بينما يراه اخرون اسما مجردا من
محتواه سامر الكبيسي العربيه بغداد
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات